Welcome students to
the last lecture in
our foundational
pharmacology series,
Drug Interactions.
We've talked about
various mechanisms
of pharmacodynamic
actions, pharmacokinetic
actions. So
now we're going to
see how they apply
in drug interactions.
We'll talk
about mechanisms
and the effects.
Please contact me if
you'd like to chat about
pharmacology. Groups
and individuals are
welcome. we can do it
in person or by zoom.
Learning
objectives. I'm sure
you're familiar
with the concept
of learning
objectives by now.
This lecture will
demonstrate
how to classify
the drug interactions
to describe the various
mechanisms both
pharmacodynamic and
pharmacokinetic. I'll
be asking you to be able
to list by name
certain inducers and
inhibitors of the CYP3A4
and p-glycoproteins
and the effects of smoking
on the CYP1A family
and you should be
able to give examples
of drug interactions
both that cause that
are for beneficial
effect and those that
can cause adverse, can
increase the risk of
adverse effects, and
explain how these drug
interactions affect
the various tissues.
Mechanisms, mechanisms,
mechanisms, and effects.
I want to emphasize
that I give you a
number of learning
resources. You certainly
do not need to
study all of them.
Gain your knowledge by
whatever means works
for you. You don't even
have to watch these
videos if you don't
want to. You do need
to do the practice
questions. I require those
because they're going
to help you. They'll
help you become
familiar with exam style
questions. They'll help
you assess your own
knowledge. They'll
help you know what you
don't know and what you
do know and it gives
you an opportunity to
apply the concepts.
Some links if you wish to
use them and
some key points.
This gives you an
overview of what
the lecture is
about and also will
focus you on what
is needed to learn.
Knowledge of drug
-drug, drug-food, drug
-botanicals, drug
-disease interactions,
careful selection of
therapeutic alternatives,
and continuously
continuous monitoring
to identify adverse
effects could
reduce the risks of
adverse drug events.
Sometimes we have
drug-drug interactions
that are okay. We
might need to adjust a
little bit. Sometimes we
have drug interactions
that really should be
avoided and we need
to know what are the
alternatives that
can be prescribed in
the event that we have
a drug interaction
that should be avoided.
Here is a scheme
from the Goodman
and Gilman
Pharmacological
Basis of Therapeutics
textbook.
It's divided into the
pharmacokinetic and
pharmacodynamic mechanisms.
The pharmacokinetic
mechanisms appear on
the left-hand side,
absorption, distribution,
metabolism, elimination,
and the interactions
can affect an overall
increase or
decrease in plasma
concentration. An increase
in plasma concentration
increases the risk
of adverse effects.
A decrease increases
the potential that
the drug will not
be fully effective.
Excuse me. Go back.
Pharmacodynamic
mechanisms.
We have drugs that
increase the overall
effect, additive synergistic
potentiation. I want
to point out that
the terms synergistic
and potentiation are commonly
used interchangeably,
and I will use them
interchangeably.
Goodman and Gilman
indicates here how they
can be differentiated
from each other,
but the differentiation
is really tiny.
An additive effect is
the combined effect
of two drugs equals the
sum of the effect of
each agent given
alone. In other words,
if a patient is getting
drug A and drug A is
doubled, then it will
be a double effect.
If a person is getting
drug A and drug B
and the two drugs do
the same thing, that
will be a double effect,
an additive effect.
Synergy is the combined
effect exceeds the
sum of the effect of
each drug given alone.
So it's a greater
effect than the
sum of the two, an
enhanced effect.
Some antagonistic
mechanisms are,
I'm going to say
receptor first.
Receptor mechanisms
blockade of the
effect of one drug
by the other that
competes at a common
binding site or a
drug that acts at
an allosteric site,
which will block the
effect of the other drug.
A physiological
antagonist is two drugs
that produce opposite
functional effects.
It's about the
function on this one.
And I'll give examples
of that. I've given
examples before, and
we will revisit that.
Keep pushing the
wrong button.
And chemical antagonism
is just a direct
reaction between two
chemicals. A chemical
and a drug, for
example, are two drugs.
I'm giving you a
number of examples of
the mechanisms and
the effects, and I
will be using drug
names in these
examples because that's
how you're going to
meet them in life
and your practice.
You should be able
to explain the
mechanisms and effects.
You do not need to
remember the drug
names at this time.
Later, yes.
The point is, one
of the points is, to
help you be able to
pick out the specific
clues in questions,
quizzes and exams,
that will help you to
identify the answers.
Sometimes students
get lost in the drug
names and forget to
notice the actual clues.
So I encourage you
to read carefully,
discern what's important
information, and
focus on that.
Beginning now with
the pharmacodynamic
mechanisms of
drug interactions.
So additive first,
the sum of the
effect of each
agent given alone.
Diphenhydramine is
Benadryl, and it
has a number of
different actions. We
always think about
it in terms of its
effects at blocking
the actions of
histamine, but it
does other things too.
And tricyclic
antidepressants, we think
about their effects for
alleviating depression,
but it has other
actions too. And in
fact, the actions of
diphenhydramine and
tricyclic antidepressants
on the cholinergic
system are the same.
So, anticholinergic
side effects.
Both drugs cause
anticholinergic side
effects, use them together,
it increases the risk
of anticholinergic
side effects. So,
what is the meaning?
What kind of side effects
are anticholinergic?
Dry mouth, Blurry
vision, drowsiness,
memory problems,
confusion, inability
to concentrate,
constipation, and
difficulty urinating.
So those are
very difficult
for patients to tolerate.
nitroglycerin
plus the erectile
dysfunction drug viagra
and all the others
for that matter
both increase levels
of nitric oxide
by different
mechanisms and nitric
oxide is a powerful
vasodilator. So
the two together
can cause profound,
potentially
catastrophic hypotension.
Hypotension causes
patients to fall.
This is categorized
as additive. I want
to mention you may
have heard of it in
other contexts as
being synergistic. The
literature doesn't
seem to agree on this.
Now, synergy and
potentiation, the
enhanced effect
exceeds the sum of the
effects of the two
drugs given alone.
So, codeine and
acetaminophen are a
really fine example
of this, common.
Codeine is an opiate
painkiller, and
acetaminophen is
Tylenol, for mild to
moderate pain.
Together, they enhance
the analgesic effect
of each other.
Another benefit
besides improved pain
relief is that lower
doses may be enough.
Lower doses of each
drug may be enough
to produce the pain
relief. So lower
doses is a good thing.
We remember that the
potential for side
effects is increased
with increasing
doses, by and large.
The next example
is a sulfonamide, a
sulfa drug, together
with another drug
called trimethoprim.
They work at different
places on the same
pathway, but so
different mechanisms.
And used together,
they enhance
antibacterial action.
Additionally,
they are less likely,
or I should say
it takes more steps,
for the organism to
develop resistance
against the drugs.
The third one down,
amoxicillin, is
an antibacteria
drug, an antibiotic.
I'm sure you're
probably familiar with
it. and clavulanic
acid, I put here in
quotes, a bodyguard.
That's kind of how I
think about it, produces
enhanced antibacterial
activity. Clavulanic
acid doesn't have
much antibacterial
activity of its own,
but it will protect
the amoxicillin from
being broken down by
bacterial enzymes.
And therefore,
that enhances
the amoxicillin
activity. So,
enhanced antibacterial
activity.
Obviously, this is
a beneficial effect.
And now, methadone,
which is a drug for
opioid use disorder,
plus itraconazole,
which is an antifungal,
commonly used,
together can cause
ventricular arrhythmia.
and this ventricular
arrhythmia
is called
torsade de point
which is indicated
right here
and you don't have to
be a cardiologist to
recognize that this ekg
tracing looks bad it
is quite dangerous it's
a ventricular arrhythmia
and it's called
torsade de point the
twisting of the points
because of these various
it's like about like
a ballet this is a
ballet term twisting of
the points both of these
drugs increase the qt
interval on the ecg
qt is this part
some antagonistic
mechanisms
will do competitive
non-competitive
physiologic and chemical.
Examples of competitive
antagonism are
morphine and the
antidote naloxone.
Morphine is a mu opioid
receptor agonist.
Naloxone is a mu opioid
receptor antagonist.
It's easy to see they
work at the same site.
Naloxone is
effective in the
treatment of
opioid overdose.
They act now Now,
there is a potential
adverse effect of this
combination, and that
is that use of naloxone
can induce abrupt
withdrawal symptoms.
So that's just
something that needs to
be managed when saving
someone's life from
an opioid overdose.
another example is a
nerve agent which is
a poison plus
atropine which is an
anticholinergic i
mentioned anticholinergics
before it blocks a
cholinergic receptor
called the m3 receptor
and atropine is used
in the treatment
of this nerve agent
poisoning because it
will block the effect
of the acetylcholine
that's released, that
accumulates, and it
will block the effects
on the various
muscarinic receptors.
It's actually
M1 through M5.
And non-competitive
antagonism, I'm sure
you remember that
mechanism, so it's binding
of a drug to an
allosteric site, the
point is it can still
block the effect of
the agonist. And the
common example used
here is ketamine.
You may have heard of
ketamine. It's long been
used as an anesthetic,
recently been used
in the management
of depression, and it
is a drug of *****.
So ketamine, which
is known as an NMDA
receptor antagonist,
will block the effects of
glutamate, which is
the neurotransmitter.
So that is therapeutic
for its anesthetic
effect, but an adverse
effect of this combination
that actually occurs
when it's used for
anesthesia or for
depression is a dissociative
effect and you'll
learn about that when
we get to talking about
the drug ketamine.
Physiologic
antagonism is as I
mentioned previously
functional.
It's the opposite
physiologic effect that
occurs the opposite
function. The typical
example is insulin, which
is a natural hormone
and also used as a
drug, and glucagon,
a natural hormone and
also used as a drug.
So insulin
causes the uptake
of blood glucose
into cells.
Glucose increases
blood glucose by
stimulating hepatic
synthesis. So one is
reduction of blood
sugar, the other is
increase in blood sugar.
Why would glucagon
be used? It will
be for reversal of
hypoglycemia. Now,
we also have a drug
interaction with
regard to blood
glucose. So insulin,
we know what that is.
Prednisone is a
steroid in a class
called glucocorticoid.
It's a powerful
drug for management
of inflammation.
insulin decreases
blood sugar, prednisone
increases blood sugar,
and that effect of
prednisone on the
blood glucose can lead
to hyperglycemia in
patients. Long-term
use of prednisone,
especially higher doses,
is known to cause
hyperglycemia, which
can actually move into
diabetes mellitus.
Chemical antagonism,
that's just the
direct binding of
one on the other.
The common example is
protamine, which is
a cationic substance
that combines with
heparin, just a one
-on-one, and activates
heparin by preventing
it from getting
to the site of action
and carries it away.
So that's a beneficial
reversal agent.
Antacids, something
like Mylanta, Tums,
chelates, tetracycline,
which is an
antibiotic, and it
happens in the gut because
the antacid stays
in the gut, and that
reduces the antibiotic
from being absorbed,
which, of course, will
reduce blood levels,
which will reduce
antibiotic efficacy.
So that's actually also a
pharmacokinetic
mechanism, that last one.
So mechanisms,
absorption,
distribution,
metabolism, excretion,
absorption, sequestration
of a drug in the
gut, as we said with
the antacid and the
tetracycline, or
increased gastric pH for
drugs that require an
acid pH for absorption.
So if absorption is
decreased, that's
going to reduce the
therapeutic effect.
Distribution.
Well, changes in
volume of distribution.
So that's a drug
-disease interaction.
Drug-disease related
to distribution.
And that can affect
the amount of drug in
plasma, which will
affect the amount of drug
that reaches the site
of action so depending
on what's happening
what the particular
drug interaction is it
can increase the risk
of adverse effects or
reduce the therapeutic
efficacy now P
glycoprotein this is going
to come up over and
over and over and over
because it is such an
important ABC efflux
transporter, ATP-using
efflux transporter.
So if we inhibit
p-glycoprotein,
which effluxes
drugs, it pushes
them out of the
bloodstream,
that can increase
systemic drug
levels and that
can increase
the risk of
adverse effects.
Induction is
also possible.
Metabolism inhibiting
or inducing drug
metabolizing
enzymes may decrease
or increase clearance,
respectively,
affecting the
risk of adverse
effects or
therapeutic effect.
Excretion, same concepts
here, inhibiting
the secretion of a
drug into the nephron,
and I've indicated
some transporters here,
OATs, organic anion
transporters, organic
cation transporters,
can decrease the
clearance. It's not
getting into the kidney,
so it stays in the
bloodstream, and that
can increase the risk
of adverse effects.
So let's see now
if you can answer
these questions.
Activating key
transcription factors
and increasing
the expression of
cytochrome P450.
What does that do?
Induction, so a drug,
let's say drug B,
that induces metabolism
by activating these
transcription factors
and increasing the
expression of CYPs or
UGTs or whatever will
increase the rate of
metabolism of drug A
and that in turn will
decrease the amount of
drug that actually
gets into the systemic
circulation. So decreased
bioavailability,
and that will potentially
reduce efficacy.
Now, competitive
binding of drugs to the
P450 heme iron. So
competitive inhibition.
I just gave
away the answer.
So this is a very, very
common mechanism of
drug-drug interactions,
drug B competing at
the CYP or the UGT or
whatever metabolizing
enzyme for the substrate.
And that's going
to reduce the rate
of metabolism of the
substrate. And that
can increase the
bioavailability,
increased levels
in the bloodstream,
can increase the risk
of adverse effects.
Now,
covalent interaction
with P450 hemoiety
or the protein itself
is known as what?
It's called suicide
inhibition. Why
suicide? Because
that enzyme is
taken out of
commission permanently.
So how is the function
of these enzymes
regained? Well, the cell
has to make new enzymes
and set them out there
ready for action.
And that takes time.
This is a scheme to
help you understand
the actual mechanism
of the induction of
drug metabolizing enzymes,
drug enters a cell,
obviously, interacts
with nuclear
receptor, and that's
going to induce gene
transcription, and that
will increase mRNA and
protein synthesis.
They go together. And
that will increase
the rate of metabolism
because there are now
more enzymes available
to metabolize the
substrate, and that
will decrease the
concentration of the
substrate drug in the
systemic circulation.
The result, the
effect, to decrease the
pharmacologic action
of the substrate drug,
and for some, the
inducer even itself,
plus increase the
concentration of reactive
metabolites.
If the drug is
metabolized to
reactive metabolites,
toxic metabolites,
that can exacerbate
that metabolite
-mediated toxicity.
Please don't
forget that point.
Okay, our starred
drugs now. These are
drugs that, yes,
I'm asking you to
memorize them. They
will be coming up
over and over and
over, and they will
become second nature
to you. So now
would be a good time
to start on them.
I've put some mnemonics
down here that
artificial intelligence
came up with for me.
Please feel free
to make your own
mnemonics, whatever
works. So the CYP3A4
and P-glycoprotein
inducers are these
anti-seizure drugs,
phenytoin, carbamazepine,
phenobarbital,
this antibiotic,
rifampin, and
this botanical,
so it's available
over the counter.
St. John's
wort, people do
that to make
them feel better.
It supposedly has
antidepressant effects.
So phenytoin, carbamazepine,
phenobarbital,
rifampin, and
St. John's wort.
AI came up with
precision care
promotes robust
scientific journeys.
I'm also bringing to
your attention CYP1A2.
CYP1A2. It's not
a big piece of the
metabolism pie, but
it's an important piece.
CYP1A2 is widely
expressed in the liver.
CYP1A1 is
expressed in other
tissues and also
can be induced.
Smoking. Smoking of
cigarettes, *********
will increase exposure
to these compounds,
polycyclic aromatic
hydrocarbons. I put a picture
of them down here.
You can see these are
these flat six-membered
circles stuck together.
So PAH is, of course,
it has an acronym.
These are metabolized
by CYP1A2, and they
can form procarcinogens.
The smoking itself
will induce CYP1A2,
which will induce
the metabolism of the
substrates. Not only
these compounds, but
also drugs. And a big
drug that we think
about is Clozapine.
Clozapine is an
antipsychotic drug. It's
quite efficacious, very
efficacious, but it
has some pretty serious
adverse effects.
Patients who are
taking clozapine for
schizophrenia or
other types of
problems will have an
increase in the rate
of metabolism if
they are smokers.
Now, why does this
matter? Because the doses
can be adjusted
according to the person's
smoking habit. Well,
if they find themselves
in a situation where
they're not able to
smoke, such as if they're
in the hospital or if
they quit smoking,
then the dose of the
clozapine is going to have
to be adjusted downward
as the CYP1A2 system
returns to normal.
Let me see if
I can clarify
that explanation
a little bit.
But the CYP1A2
is induced by
cigarette smoking,
which means
we get more CYPs
available to
metabolize their
substrates. And this is
true for any enzymes
that are induced. once
the inducer is removed
in this case the
smoking then the number
of the enzymes will
return to normal or
the the pre-induced
level now if a patient
is taking clozapine
a ****** is taking
clozapine and the
dose has been adjusted
according to the
person's smoking
activities so they get the
therapeutic blood
levels, if that person
stops smoking for any
reason, such as going
into the hospital
where smoking is not
allowed, those enzymes
will reduce in number
back to their pre
-smoking concentration.
Now, the patient is
on the Clozapine at
this higher dose,
because of the induction,
this higher dose will
produce higher blood
levels once those
CYP1A2 enzymes return
to their original
concentration.
Therefore,
clozapine doses must
be adjusted downwards
in patients who
stop smoking.
I hope I was able to make
that clearer for you.
inhibition now of drug
metabolizing enzymes.
It's basically the
same concept as we
talked about for
pharmacodynamic mechanisms.
Drugs or the reactive
intermediates could
be one or both that
bind to the active site
or an allosteric site
of drug metabolizing
enzymes will decrease
the catalytic enzyme
activity of the enzyme
for the substrate.
And some mechanisms
are competitive
inhibition of the
CYP heme iron. We
talked about that.
Non-competitive
binding to the allosteric
site, preventing
binding to the
substrate. We talked
about that. And
suicide inhibition
that irreversibly binds
to the drug metabolizing
enzyme. Covalent
binding with the heme
that's in there.
Covalent binding to the
protein part of the
enzyme or anything that
can cause a fragmentation
of the protein.
So that's just a recap.
So some CYP3A4
inhibitors. You
notice these have
stars on them.
These are commonly
used drugs.
You should be aware
of them. There are
so many, many, many
CYP3A4 inhibitors out
there. I've just
picked out some strong
ones that are commonly
used. So cymetidine
is an over-the
-counter antacid. It's
called Tagamet. It's
also called cymetidine.
It is available
generically, and
many people take it
to calm stomach acid.
Ytriconazole is
an antifungal
agent and a strong CYP3A4
inhibitor and also
p-glycoprotein.
Erysromycin,
clarissromycin. These
are commonly
used antibiotics.
I'm sure you've
heard of them.
They're in the
macrolides class.
Ritonavir.
Ritonavir we are going
to be talking about
later on. It's a very
important drug for
its pharmacokinetic
effects, actually, more
so than for its
therapeutic effects. It is
called a pharmacokinetic
enhancer, and I
want you to be familiar
with this concept.
It is one of the strongest
CYP3A4 inhibitors
out there, and it
is used specifically
for the purpose
of increasing the
bioavailability and half
-life, thus duration,
of certain CYP3A4
substrates. not
all, but specific ones.
So I put this graph
here to remind you
about what happens
when we inhibit the
metabolic process
of a drug.
So both lines are
the same drug,
the CYP3A4
inhibitor, whatever
it is we're
talking about.
And this would be
representative
of the half
-life without
the ritonavir.
Peak concentration
rapidly drops.
With ritonavir,
and let's just
pretend this is
the minimum
therapeutic effect.
Okay.
So we can see it
drops below at this
point in time with
ritonavir inhibiting the
enzyme that degrades
this mystery drug
we see the half-life
increases and the
duration above the
therapeutic minimum
therapeutic efficacy
line is much longer
see this difference
in time right here.
So that is why it's
called a pharmacokinetic
enhancer. You may
have also heard it
as a booster,
pharmacokinetic booster.
So it increases
peak concentrations
and half-life of
CYP3A4 substrates.
In this example, the peak
concentration is
the same, but this
could theoretically
be here.
Now grapefruit
juice, well
that's not a
drug. It's a food.
I personally love
grapefruit juice.
Many people love
Well grapefruit juice
has a substance in
it that is a CYP3A4
inhibitor and hence that
is why the recommendation
is to never take
any drugs together
with grapefruit juice
that's just to be on
the side to err on the
side of caution but
so many drugs of
cyp3a4 substrates that
it's better to just
avoid grapefruit juice
whenever anybody's
taking medication period
i put a mnemonic down
here that ai helped
me with clinical
insights enhance care
research grows clinical
insights enhanced care
research grows i've
been talking about
various cyps and a piece
of the pie and we
saw this earlier so
i'm bringing it back
now the fraction of
clinically used drugs
metabolized by the major
phase one and phase
two enzymes based
on the literature the
relative size of each
pie section represents
the estimated
percentage of drugs
metabolized by each of
them. So on the top,
we have our phase one,
CYPs. We also
have esterases
and epoxide
hydrolases indicated
here. They're
also phase one.
Others. Here's our
CYP1A family, tiny,
but important.
They're all important.
CYP3A4, it's nearly half,
that's a lot of
drugs, CYP2D6,
we'll be talking,
we talked
about that in
pharmacogenomics,
pretty decent
size of the pie,
lots of important
drugs, and so on.
Here we have phase
two enzymes, our
UGTs, our UDP
glucuronaciltransferases,
or
glucuronaltransferases,
is the greater portion
of the pie, and
the others are also
still important.
Let's talk about the drug
-disease interactions now.
Some therapies can
worsen existing
medical
conditions. So some
drugs can worsen
hypertension,
can interfere with
antihypertensive drugs.
some lots of drugs
go through the liver
some drugs can can
exacerbate liver disease
or kidney disease
or heart disease a
peripheral vascular
disease diabetes so
drugs that cause increased
blood glucose are
going to exacerbate
diabetes drugs that
are irritating to the
stomach peptic ulcer
disease drugs that
increase levels of
uric acid in the blood
can aggravate gout.
Drugs that can inhibit
breathing can
aggravate asthma.
Hypo or hyperthyroid
problems, and
there are special
problems of the
elderly. So I've
indicated down here.
Older individuals are
twice as likely as
younger adults to have
adverse drug reactions.
All our physiology
changes as we become an
older adult, elderly,
and that can increase
adverse drug reactions,
adverse drug events,
and seven more
times likely to be
hospitalized of an
adverse drug event. These
patients tend to have
more comorbidities, and
are on drug therapies
with multiple drugs.
So all of that increases
the risk of adverse
drug reactions and
adverse drug events.
So let's test our
knowledge now.
I suggest that you
might want to pause the
video in order to
have a look at these
questions, think about
them, see if you can
answer them without
looking back, and if you
can, then certainly
look back, then stop
looking, and then say
the answer out loud. Drug
A is taken ****** to
increase gastric pH.
The absorption of
drug B requires an
acid stomach for
optimal absorption.
What is the
potential effect on
blood levels when
the two drugs
are administered
concomitant?
Well, this is a
pharmacokinetic
mechanism of action.
Systemic levels of
drug B are decreased,
which could
result in reduced
therapeutic efficacy
of the antifungal
drug, which is
drug B by the way.
A drug that is a
positive allosteric
modulator enhances
the inhibitory effects
of a chloride ion
channel in the CNS.
Alcohol is
also a positive
allosteric modulator
at the same
target but at a
different site.
So they both have the
same effect. What is
the likely adverse
drug effect when the
two chemicals are used
simultaneously? In
this case, it's synergy.
Synergistic CNS
depressant effects
may lead to
death. This is a
common, common,
unfortunately,
drug combination that
does lead to adverse
outcomes and death.
So it's important that
you understand the
combination of a
benzodiazepine and alcohol,
which is what we're
talking about here,
and especially a mu
-opioid receptor agonist
with it, an opioid.
A patient is taking
an antiplatelet drug
following a heart attack
and an anticoagulant
due to recent knee
replacement surgery.
What is the potential
adverse drug effect
that could result
from this drug-drug
interaction. So you know
what platelets do. So
an antiplatelet reduces
what platelets do,
and an anticoagulant
reduces coagulation.
So this is
pharmacodynamic, an
additive or synergistic
effect that can
lead to potentially
serious bleeding,
including
hemorrhagic ******.
Patient with several
comorbidities treated
with various drugs is
evaluated for an oral
antiviral drug that
contains a potent CYP3A4
inhibitor for the
treatment of COVID-19.
What effects may be
anticipated when the
antiviral is taken
together with the
patient's chronic
medications? So I didn't
mention what the
chronic medications
are. We're talking
about the potential.
Depending on what
the patient is
taking, we always
need to be thinking
about that first
and then checking.
This is a pharmacokinetic
metabolism mechanism.
Inhibiting the metabolism
of the concurrent
drugs that are CYP3A4
substrates can lead to
elevated blood levels
of the substrate drugs
and increase the risk
of adverse effects.
What can the
prescriber do to
mitigate the potential
adverse effects
of this drug
-drug interaction.
Concomitant use of
many other medications
with this particular
oral COVID-19 antiviral
drug should be avoided.
This happens to be
a so-called black box
warning from the FDA.
Prescribers should
refer to published drug
interaction information
for prescribing
guidance. So what this
prescribing guidance will
tell you is whether
or not the drug can be
given together, possibly
dose adjustment.
And if the drugs can't
be given together,
then you're going to
have to have knowledge
to recognize what
alternatives there may be.
An 87-year-old patient
with compensated
congestive heart failure
takes a medication
that is a p-glycoprotein
substrate has a narrow
therapeutic window
and a potential for
serious toxicity notice
those three features
p-glycoprotein efflux
narrow therapeutic
window potential for
serious toxicity she's
evaluated for antibiotic
therapy for bacterial
lung infection. The
preferred drug is a
P-glycoprotein
inhibitor. What is the
potential effect of this
drug-drug interaction?
So this is
pharmacokinetic again.
Remembering that P
-glycoprotein is expressed
in the intestinal tract
and it pushes drug
out of the endothelial,
I mean the intestinal
epithelial cells
back into the lumen.
It's located in the
liver at the area where
drug gets pushed into
the biliary system,
which then goes back
into the intestine.
And it's naturally
at the blood
-brain barrier,
but that's not
what we're
talking about now.
And in the kidneys.
So it's located
in nephrons,
and it actually
pushes drug
into the nephron
for excretion.
So by blocking p
-glycoprotein, we are
reducing all that efflux
activity, which can
increase the amount
of drug that gets
into the systemic
system, increasing blood
levels. this drug has
a narrow therapeutic
window and a high
potential for toxicity.
So even a small
increase in blood levels
can significantly
increase the risk of
adverse, actually an
adverse drug event.
A 57-year-old patient
with long-standing
type 2 diabetes
mellitus takes an ACE
inhibitor, an angiotensin
-converting enzyme
inhibitor, for its what
is called reno-protective
effects, reno
referring to kidney, by
reducing glomerular
filtration pressure,
which, in turn,
reduces mechanical
stress on the
glomerular capillaries.
Patient education,
which of course would
be an easy-to-understand
language, includes
the caution that
the patient should
not take any over-the
-counter pain medications
known as NSAIDs
like ibuprofen or
Aleve that also decrease
glomerular filtration
pressure. So we
have the medication
prescribed medication
that's reducing
glomerular filtration
pressure and the painkiller
that's reducing
glomerular filtration
pressure. So what
do you think is the
potential effect of
this drug interaction?
Well, this is a drug
disease interaction.
Number one, the patient
has long-standing
diabetes mellitus, and
that is the disease.
The NSAID on its
own can increase the
risk of kidney injury
in these patients.
And it's a pharmacodynamic
interaction
because of the
synergistic effects
of the NSAID and
the ACE inhibitor,
the synergistic
negative effects,
on glomerular
filtration rate,
which could lead
to acute kidney
injury in the
vulnerable patient.
Last question.
I think it's the last
question. A patient
with hypercholesterolemia
who has not
achieved goal lipid
levels with statin
therapy agrees to the
addition of a bile acid
sequestrant, which
is a resin that forms
a complex with bile
acids in the gut.
The drug bile acid's
complex is excreted in
the feces. The patient
is advised to take
the statins several
hours after the resin
because the resin can
also sequester drugs.
Why separate the
administration
of the two drugs
by several hours?
This is pharmacokinetic,
obviously.
When taken at the same
time or near the same
time, the resin will
sequester many drugs,
not only bile acids,
preventing absorption
and resulting in
reduced blood levels and
reduced efficacy of
the ****** absorbed
drugs such as statin.
This is a situation that
can be overcome by
separating the dosing
of the two drugs. So
the cholesteiromene
has a chance to move
through the gut before
the statin is taken.
And the statin will be
absorbed in the proximal
small intestine.
And now our summary.
Drug interactions
occur when one drug
modifies the actions
of another drug.
Drug interactions
can result from
pharmacokinetic
alterations,
pharmacodynamic changes,
or a combination.
Pharmacodynamic
characteristics of the
different drugs
administered can lead to
additive synergistic or
antagonistic effects.
Pharmacokinetic
interactions are related
to absorption
distribution metabolism
excretion and may
increase or decrease
blood levels depending
on what's actually
happening, depending
on the mechanism.
Strong inducers
of CYP3A4 and P
-glycoprotein include
carbamazepine,
phenobarbital, phenytoin,
rifampin, and
St. John's Wort.
CYP1A2 isoenzymes
are induced by
tobacco and also
********* smoking.
Clinically relevant
CYP3A4 and p
-glycoprotein inhibitors
include cimetidine,
the macrolite
antibiotics,
erythromycin and
clarithromycin,
azole antifungals,
ritonavir,
grapefruit juice,
and many more.
Exaggerated drug
effects and other
toxicities, as well
as reduced efficacy,
can all lead to
adverse drug events.
And I separated
this out in a little
chart for you,
a flow diagram.
And here are the
test your knowledge
questions. And
that concludes
the drug
interactions lecture.